first it appears to be the biggest
election and presidential spying scandal
in the history of this great country i'm
going to go through this slowly because
without a doubt
un unequivocally the trump campaign
their campaign their transition team
even the trump white house meaning the
president was spied on
by the clinton campaign it is far worse
than what we have known till now and
we've reported on this now for three
years now thanks to a brand new filing
from the special counsel john durham we
now know that the clinton campaign paid
a tech firm to infiltrate the servers at
trump tower and then later infiltrate
the servers at the trump white house in
other words illegally spying on a
presidential candidate and later a
president of the united states they were
in gold fabricate evidence that
president trump was a russian asset or a
russian stooge of some kind but make no
mistake
this is far worse than watergate so
let's go through this step by step let
me refresh many people's memories maybe
you don't have a reference point of
watergate the watergate scandal involved
associates that will link to the 1972
nixon reelection campaign these
associates they broke into dnc
headquarters at washington dc's
watergate office building they stole
campaign documents they attempted to bug
phones in the end
69 people were indicted 48 people were
convicted and richard nixon ended up
resigning in disgrace for his part in
the cover-up of this now of course
business has conducted a little
differently in 1972 versus you know 2016
when this all went down in the age of
the internet you don't need to break
into a building to steal uh your
opponent's information you just need
access to their server and that is
exactly what the clinton campaign did
but here's where this is even worse than
watergate not only did they hack into
the opposing campaign and steal material
like in the case of watergate but then
they hacked into the office of the
president of this great country
according to durham's blockbuster filing
late friday this is something maybe we
would expect from russia china iran
north korea not an american political
campaign and clearly the clinton machine
was willing to do anything and
everything legal and illegal to win an
election and when that didn't work to
then smear and destroy the guy that
legitimately won that election if this
filing is accurate it is all illegal
everyone involved should go to jail just
like watergate except this is far worse
don't take my word for it take a look at
what nancy pelosi once had to say
after the democratic congressional
campaign committee was hacked in a
similar fashion by a foreign government
not by republicans in 2016. take a look
in terms of the presidential campaign
this is an electronic watergate
this is an electronic watergate this is
a break in
this is a break-in
and i think that we have to recognize
uh
what is happening here now who
the russians broke in who did they give
the information to i don't know who
dumped it i don't know but i do know
that this is a watergate like electronic
break-in
oh nancy's right that hillary clinton's
campaign was involved in an
electronic watergate but now surprise
surprise nancy is totally completely
utterly silent about durham's revelation
so is the biden administration now the
executive office of the president was
surveilled but the white house can't be
bothered to answer one single question
about it maybe that's because biden's
national security adviser that guy right
there jake sullivan he is at the center
of this entire scandal and here's where
the story takes yet another turn stay
with us after infiltrating the servers
at the trump tower and the executive
office of the president and spying on
her opponent and then the president the
clinton campaign found no evidence in
any form or fashion that trump was a
russian asset so they just fabricated
all of this out of thin air jake
sullivan was a senior policy advisor for
hillary clinton in 2016 propagated a
bogus story about trump's secret line to
russia naturally sullivan's wife just to
make it even more interesting works for
the attorney general of the united
states merrick garland who oversees the
durham probe she would need to recuse
herself he would need to recuse her
immediately she should have done this on
day one republicans need to demand that
the a.g in this case case takes her off
anything involving the dorm
investigation immediately jake sullivan
he needs to now answer questions about
his role in the clinton campaign's
illicit activities as of now in other
words what did he know what did hillary
know when did they know it mitch
mcconnell by the way where are you in
all this is spying on a president and
presidential candidates is it okay with
everybody in washington think about what
we knew before this filing of john doram
and what we've known for a long time and
what we spent nearly three years
investigating right here on this show we
knew about christopher steele's debunked
dirty russian misinformation dossier
bought and paid for by hillary clinton
and of course the money was funneled
through a law firm perkins cui and
fusion gps and they hire christopher
steele we told you that story a million
times the fbi then used that material as
the basis for the russia witch hunt and
by the way to do that the top of a fisa
warrant says verified we now know it's
totally debunked none of it was true it
was all unverifiable when they found out
it was unverified they still continue to
use hillary's dirty russian dossier the
fisa warrants against the trump campaign
associate carter page guess what they
did it all this is even worse than all
of that according to andrew mccabe if
there's no dossier there would be no
fisa warrant granted now we know that
hillary clinton and her campaign was
spying on donald trump's internet
activity as a matter of fact the entire
trump tower the entire white house as a
candidate and by the way now as
president that too was bought and paid
for by hillary clinton's attorneys and
when they came up empty jake sullivan
was more than happy to disseminate
unverified rumors and conspiracy
theories as fact in other words
president trump he was right the whole
time this might remind you so the
biggest scandal was when they spied on
my campaign they spied on my campaign
there's no real evidence of that of
course there is it's all over the place
leslie they spied on my campaign and
they got called can i say something
you know this is 60 minutes
and we can't put on things we can't
verify it on because it's bad for
abiding we can't put on things we can't
verify leslie they spied on my campaign
it's been totally verified no
it's been just go down and get the
papers
they spied on my campaign they got
caught no and then they went much
further than that and they got caught
and you will see that leslie and you
know that but you just don't want to put
it
as a matter of fact i don't know that
okay
leslie now you do so now you can go on
60 minutes on sunday and issue an
apology we'll be waiting for that
i doubt they even cover the story and by
the way the same goes for fake news cnn
they spent three years lying to the
american people msdnc by the way
probably a very convenient time for the
conspiracy theorists uh of all time
rachel maddow to be on quote leave you
know what they gave more time to this
than any other story three years of the
trump presidency and you think they
would spend a minute and and inform
their viewers that they were wrong the
entire time and update them on this new
development where's bob woodward where's
bernstein carl bernstein anyway remember
they once cared about quote journalism
through their top secret source deep
throat they broke the watergate story
wide open now they are nowhere to be
found and apparently you know for them
politics is much more important than
quote journalism now the reason the
media will ignore this story
that is bigger than watergate is because
they are accomplices the entire time
they have lied the entire time they
advance their propaganda almost 24 hours
a day seven days a week and they did it
for over three years they knew and they
know the dossier was alive but their
hatred of donald trump was more
important than the truth they have never
set the record straight they never made
a correction they never admitted that
they were wrong the new york times the
washington post oh they got pulitzers
for false stories maggie it's time to
return it and by the way what about the
congenital liar adam schiff
he sits on the january 6 committee and
they said campaign uh rhetoric and and
and talk about elections has has brought
us to this point
okay adam schiff or you know whatever we
want to call you the congenital liar if
you really care about election
interference is it okay
when hillary clinton does it because
adam schiff on that january 6 committee
is the biggest purveyor of election
fraud lies ever
he's going to be critical of donald
trump uh we need an investigation into
him and thankfully durham doesn't take
orders from schiff or fake news cnn or
anyone else in the media mob
john durham he's been taking forever but
he's supposedly looking for the truth
and he's given us a window into what
he's finding and to that end according
to foxnews.com his probe is accelerating
more people are cooperating and
testifying before a grand jury i can't
predict what dorm will ultimately find
nobody's been held accountable for the
lies they made to the fisa court that we
know they made lies they knew they were
lying but i do know that as of now
all roads lead back to one person and
one campaign that's hillary clinton and
her campaign and i hope one day very
soon her campaign will be held
accountable for the worst political
spying scandal in the history of this
country that's how important it is hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else